- So I do freestyle rap that's improvised,
made up on the spot based
entirely on your suggestions.
It's not written, prepared or rehearsed.
So therefore you, everyone in this room
needs to start thinking
of a word, a topic,
or a phrase you'd like a rap about.
We'll get five suggestions,
then we'll drop a beat.
If you are sat in this
rectangular segment here
running to the wall, what
would you like a wrap about?
- [Man] Will Smith.
- Will Smith. What specifically about him?
And don't say the thing
that you're thinking of.
(audience laughing)
Come on.
There's more to that man than
just being a massive dickhead.
(audience laughing)
- [Man] Men In Black.
- Men In black.
Okay, Will Smith in Men In Black.
Cool. Thank you very much.
And then you've gone over here.
Yeah, what'd you wanna rap about?
- [Woman] The Confederate flag.
- The Confederate flag?
(audience groaning)
No, no, no, no, no.
'Cause no, no, no.
'Cause you can say it, right?
She's not, I haven't asked.
What color underwear are you wearing?
Have you got the "South Will
Rise Again" just over there.
What's, what's specifically about it?
- [Man] Black.
- [Woman] What?
- Oh, the underwear.
Okay. Out of context, sir.
That was really weird.
(audience laughing)
Let me ask you, what, what,
what state are you from?
I mean, we can tell what state
you're in because you clearly
South Carolina.
Oh shit okay. Well we
know their opinions on it.
Men in black and Will Smith,
the Confederate flag,
blame them for that bit.
Middle of the room.
What would you guys like a rap about?
Yes.
- [Woman] Star Signs.
- Star signs. What is your star sign?
Leo. What does that mean?
It means that you make
friends really easily.
Just, just like, yes.
Did you just, you're doing this.
This is, I lived in LA for four years
and this is the type of
shit they did over there.
You're a Leo. Oh my god. Amazing. Okay.
Leo Star signs. I know nothing about them.
This corner over here so far
it's kind of a mixed bag.
You're ready to shout out.
What are you about to shout?
- [Man] Hip dysplasia.
- Hip dysplasia. Amazing. Okay, cool.
Did you suffer from hip dysplasia?
Unlikely. Cuz you are a male
and usually it affects females,
the first born. Especially
in breach births.
Yeah. I fucking paid attention.
(audience laughing)
Okay. Hip dysplasia.
That bit of the rap would be fucking sick.
It's just gonna be an information download
and then I'll just rhyme Confederate flag
and move on from that bit.
This section over here.
What do you wanna wrap about?
Oh, okay. There were two.
So you said Venetian glass blowing.
Have you been to Murano?
It's the island where they
do the Venetian glass.
So it look, look, I like, when I said, oh
maybe you went to Oxford.
I fucking did, right?
I just dress it down.
(audience clapping)
I dress it down and wear a hood.
Okay. Venetian glassblowing,
Confederate flag,
Men in black and Will
Smith, hip dysplasia,
and then the other, the
other one remind us.
- [Woman] Star signs
- Star signs, Leos, of course.
Fucking, you're still rowing.
And then there was
another one in the corner.
What was it?
What?
As, oh, oh, oh, because he's being crazy.
Okay, we'll start with that, but yeah.
Okay. Can we, can we turn
that beat up over there?
There we go.
We'll, we'll deal with Kanye briefly
and then we'll move on to the rest of it.
Let's do this.
Nice.
♪ We drop in, sound lots
when a hip hop man ♪
♪ Going crazy, interview on this ♪
♪ Fox news channel ♪
♪ Speaking to Tucker, I'm
laying back in the day ♪
♪ He had the luck with all of the albums ♪
♪ Whole nation's loving
the college dropout ♪
♪ And graduation even ♪
♪ You got the ones coming after ♪
♪ Twisted nightmare but
now it's a PR disaster ♪
♪ Kanye's people are like shit ♪
♪ I can't believe you're
so anti semantic ♪
♪ You've got a maybe,
go and see a therapist ♪
♪ I've a daughter, got a
problem with her hips ♪
♪ But we fixed it ♪
♪ Yeah you know I'm addicted ♪
♪ I know in relation,
there's more sick kids ♪
♪ She came out and they were like ♪
♪ This is very common, mild
dysplasia of the hips ♪
♪ If you don't understand,
don't get my point ♪
♪ It means, it's not firmly the socket ♪
♪ And the joint entwined ♪
♪ The hip, yes, I can tell this ♪
♪ The socket doesn't
insert to the pelvis ♪
♪ So, you gotta make sure it's harmless ♪
♪ And wear a thing
called a pavlik harness ♪
♪ It makes the legs go up like a frog ♪
♪ Someone over there is
like, he's doing the job ♪
♪ Really well, okay, I'm
taking it backwards ♪
♪ Will Smith did the slap,
but Men in Black slapped ♪
♪ I loved that movie,
I loved his rap too ♪
♪ I was like shit, I wanna ask you ♪
♪ Will, can I be your Tommy Lee Jones ♪
♪ Me, you and me, little
red line on your own ♪
♪ Take the car, with the
button that makes it go ♪
♪ Fast and the guy with the head ♪
♪ That asks can it grow back ♪
♪ Yes it does, that's the first one ♪
♪ I've never seen the sequels ♪
♪ I'm like a virgin to any of that ♪
♪ Let me ask this ♪
♪ You're just clapping over here ♪
♪ You can ask Chris ♪
♪ Do you need a beat in your show ♪
♪ I'd be like no, you'd say I'm a Leo ♪
♪ I look at the zodiac
signs, do it with precision ♪
♪ I can clap, why I've
got very good rhythm ♪
♪ Oh yes, you know the Leos provide ♪
♪ They're a group of lions
so you know they take pride ♪
♪ That's a lion pun,
you didn't even get it ♪
♪ That's okay, the star
signs, not pathetic ♪
♪ You can make friends,
you could be chums ♪
♪ Like we can go out on
Leo best friend runs ♪
♪ Running over here,
jogging through the park ♪
♪ This section of the rap's
gonna get pretty dark ♪
♪ Like your underwear ♪
♪ Alas, alack, the man on the
table said it's just black ♪
♪ Ah shit, it's kinda awkward we see ♪
♪ Over there, South Carolina, tee hee ♪
♪ The daughters of the confederacy ♪
♪ Were putting statues
everywhere so people can see ♪
♪ Saying, 'nah it's
kinda weird to say this ♪
♪ People say the
confederate flag is racist ♪
♪ But I don't think it
is', that's some opinions ♪
♪ If you actually have
that, a real silly one ♪
♪ It clearly is, it was
the symbol of the south ♪
♪ If you like 'He'll rise
again' then hush your mouth ♪
♪ Go the red or white, or
the blue with the stars ♪
♪ I don't like that, oh yes,
you know we really are ♪
♪ Having such fun, the
last thing that we'll do ♪
♪ Remind me sir, what we got from you ♪
♪ Of course, not the man,
it was the lady who said ♪
♪ I want to go to Italy, get out of bed ♪
♪ Look out my windows,
see the beautiful canal ♪
♪ All of the craftsmen,
the artisans dwell ♪
♪ Over there, what do they do ♪
♪ They're really top class ♪
♪ They get a long pipe,
start blowing all the glass ♪
♪ Turning it around,
that is how they learn ♪
♪ Take care, 'cause it's sticky ♪
♪ It can hurt when it burns ♪
♪ They make a beautiful sphere ♪
♪ Make a lovely glow ♪
♪ They sell it, make a lot of cash ♪
♪ All over the world,
Murano, that's the name ♪
♪ Of the island, I've dropped it ♪
♪ People were clapping their hands ♪
♪ Like he knows his name of a city ♪
♪ Glass so pretty ♪
♪ Used to think the only knowledge ♪
♪ He would have is pretty shitty ♪
♪ There you go, that's a rap ♪
♪ Make it hot, make it hippie ♪
♪ And with the venetian
glass, that's a little bitty ♪
(audience cheering)
- Yeah